salut keV salut à tous donc Fab ça y est
on y est à la finale de ce tournoi avec
j'ai envie de dire deux surprises si
surtout si on prend le le Field avant le
début du tournoi tous les tous les
participants retrouvés Niall Sarine et
ouais c'est son final ça devait être une
grosse côte pas facile après avoir les
deux enfin beaux parcours jusque-là ils
vont s'expliquer donc dans cette finale
et ça y est le je crois que c'est parti
écoute c'est western
là le ouais ça va enfin ça va pas
enchaîné parce que les grosses pauses
mais je pense ça va envoyer et NiAl qui
qui choisit une P3 fait là tout de suite
ceux qui se pose des questions
peut-être que des petites nulles en
quelques coups peut-être se mettre
d'accord pour 8 nuls
est-ce que West a une idée tu penses
dans dans la pétrole là tu peux envoyer
les nouveautés il y a 80 000 euros en
jeu dans dans cette dans cette finale
c'est peut-être la partie la plus chère
de l'année or candidat et un match
Championnat du Monde femme possible
qu'on a vu le premier jour on va voir
on va voir qu'il y ait des 6
trucs la nouveauté la petite idée n'a
qu'a été heureux de son idée Fab dans
l'ouverture
sa danser en conférence de presse il
devait y croire après cette première
journée car où probablement ouais mais
le chat était était sur ça sur sa route
et oui on se rappelle que ce que Douda
on voyait avant envoyer du G6 F5 à un
moment donné qu'on n'est pas trop aimé
mais c'était cette position en cavalier
abscisse on cavalier A6 on l'avait aussi
hein
ce qui était parti faire un peu les
bordures pour revenir en tout cas ce qui
est surpris ça c'est dur visuellement à
son à son visage dès l'ouverture qui a
value trois alors là il peut y avoir du
rebond alors il peut y avoir soit des
fous prends des 6 Caval F5 parfois bon
rare mais peu exister ou du cavalier G4
cavalier 5 aussi pour revenir ou même
parfois des cavaliers G4 et après des
des trucs qui arrivent vers le roi quoi
tu vois tu peux combiner avec des tours
E7 mais bon là c'est pas c'est pas
possible attention D3 plutôt bien joué
Fab on prend le le contrôle de la case
c'est quoi
ne jouait pas aujourd'hui donc ce fou
qui vient E5 il vient utiliser la case
Fab et peut-être à tout moment des ça
peut ça peut sauter après tu veux un
truc tu peux vouloir C4 c'est 5 B4 A4 B5
c'est fort ça comme plan puis on avance
à fond du London
tu reviens tu mets ta tour en B1 tu
pousses ou tu peux jouer avec
cache-cache 5 aussi c'est à le jeu des
deux côtés non mais sous doit être ravi
il se passe absolument rien il est en
danger
il doit être très bien tout toujours
Fabien être faire attention à ces coups
comme F600 ça a affaiblit des cases
attention oh tu es team fou non quand
même moi je suis team fou mais bon c'est
vrai que si le 4 et arrête le prendre
ouais mais tu reprendras de H c'est
peut-être que d'écouter content parce
que tu auras un peu de on reprend de me
prendre des cinq tu vois tu peux essayer
de pêcher
un C4 et je sais pas trop bon déjà
première option de toute façon
comprendre dame prend cavalier F5 dame
D7
faut prendre et là
mais bon
c'est un peu mieux
et ça c'est déjà avantage on peut
montrer la ligne parce que tu as un
petit centre
s'il veut ok mais peut-être pas c'est
quoi trop peut-être
les cavaliers F4 t'empêche d'aménage 5
tu auras tout H4 et tu vas faire tout à
l'heure
passer deux options équivalentes
ça fait ouais non c'est trop ça peut pas
aller ça cavalier à 6 qui est ici 7
cavalier aussi F6 cavalier C7 j'y crois
pas trop Fab
c'est un beau dessin de NFC en même
temps ouais bon tu es très bien là
je crois trop
il va te faire h6 il fera cavalière je
crois trop dame j'ai 6
c'est tellement facile ça se joue les
yeux fermés il plaise with closed Fabien
alors tu peux pas vraiment faire de
gaffe avec les Noirs non plus mais bon
le truc c'est que tu as pas trop
d'activités en fait
selon parler bon ça pion qui avance
tellement heureux de dire j'ai enfin une
position intéressante du jeu d'échec
finalement ça fait une semaine que
j'essaie d'avoir cette position
d'ailleurs j'espère qu'il me rejoint la
même ouverture à la partie retour ça
nous promet une finale on balance
beaucoup mieux que le 960 avec ses
pièces placées bizarrement il y a
beaucoup d'autres tactiques dans ce jeu
au complexe ici les mêmes difficiles de
trouver une gaffe pour les blancs alors
oui les blancs pourraient jouer dame F5
mais les Noirs la mangerait par cavalier
des six bref
menace peut-être un petit H6 un jour
peut-être du cavalier H4 pour aller vers
F5 mais alors la jauge n'aime pas du
tout à cause du coup le plus logique
d'un iPhone pour pas les bouffer le truc
mais attention parce que tu masse pas
rendre le prendre il y aurait peut-être
du C5 et à ton cavalier qui est mal donc
bon on ne sait pas du tout parce que
c'est ça qui est B5 tu auras toujours à
4 et le cavalier carrément enfermado en
Bassinko dégueulasse là-bas ah c'est
horrible Fabien bon il a joué le dame F7
Wesley qui est dégoûté d'abord
j'avais pas du tout envie quoi enfin je
recule quand je retourne en H2 tant pis
mais après il menace rien quand même
parce que enfin réellement dame prend
c'est ça
jouer offensif si il a pas envie il faut
pas jouer à contrecoeur il fait à 4
ouais bon tu vas dépasser la 5e rangée
de l'autre côté tu vas perdre tes deux
pions en fait c'est
attention quand même Wesley en tout cas
pour le moment il y a pas d'approche 5
on va remontrer pourquoi C5 attaques le
cavalier qui doit se déplacer et c'est
le deuxième cavalier dont le dans le
viseur du fou qui se fait sniper
donc l'option A4
qui avance mais si le cavalier c'est 720
il y aura une vraie menace attention
quand même
bon pourquoi
cavalier H4 avant sur damage 5 SC5
cavalier F7 full français 7 on touche la
tour
c'est des petits détails Fab mais ce
sont des détails cruciaux importants et
donc il veut venir se diriger vers F5 et
venir peut-être faire une prise à deux
c'est un peu du catch quoi et revenir
avec la dame en F5 et venir en fin
défendre le pion mécaniquement hinco
attention et H6 ça peut être aussi une
menace latente dans la position Fabien
n'a peut-être un jour ça va partir venir
comme ça pour détruire la structure et
si G6 de moins fort pour des raisons
tactiques ce serait un gros problème 5
54 contre 5 minutes le temps peut avoir
son importance ici Fabien oui même si on
a vu que ça rime pouvait jouer vite
quand même on va rentrer dans la zone de
danger dans la zone rouge dans la zone
gaffe et avec une position très
difficile à jouer côté blanc Niall
Sarine déjà en grand danger il a pris en
C4 il a joué cavalu aussi et là
évidemment la jauge rentre dans le dans
le terrain du allez être resté un 5 mais
c'est c'est pas loin de rentrer dans le
[Musique]
et sur toute la C5 a l'air fort du coup
numéro 1 de la jauge mais c'est pour
rentrer en F5 pour rentrer sur les cases
vachement et voir cavalier C8 et
peut-être cavalier F5 qui rentre
ça pourrait faire mal Fabien
attention
un petit peu non
[Musique]
bon pas évident enfin je veux dire une
fois que tu as le truc sous les yeux tu
vois bien dame G4
et C8 qui a value F100 en fait c'est
trouver par Wesley assez impressionnant
sur cette séquence de coupe à bien on va
pas évident parce que c'était dur ce que
la finale étant de jour alors oui la
finale est aussi en deux jours là faut
qu'il ait le dame F3 encore
au fait on a pu le fameux
on a pas eu le fin mot Fabien de se B6
mais il montre qu'il est il est fort et
c'est ce B6 hein quelque part qui lui a
permis de faire tourner le match au
final mais il est déjà foutu ça et oui
parce qu'il y a l'idée de dame G4 qui
est juste alors après c'était trouvable
hein il peut connaître un saut c'est
thème d'attaque parce qu'il y a quand
même beaucoup de pièces et c'est pas des
thèmes qu'on voit jamais c'est ces
attaques là donc c'est des choses qui
sont thématiques qui sont trouvables
mais trouver ça avec cinq minutes 50 sur
la pendule en une minute c'est c'est ou
une minute 30 c'est quand même assez
assez impressionnant et l'Ania le qui
suit complètement il comprend même pas
ce qu'il lui arrive en fait le pauvre
dépassé par par la vitesse de Wesley
donc il échange d'un pro de toute façon
ça change rien la tour est peut-être
mieux en 1 et on veut de toute façon
partir vers G4 ça a été prémouvant en
plus hein Wesley la la tête dans le seau
et j'ai qu'à BIM ah ouais c'est
impressionnant Wesley de gala ce soir
dans sa tenue d'étoile on va peut-être
plutôt partir sur du H6 G6 qui est
épanche si tu en prends J6 dame prend J6
38 fois H4 pour [ __ ] F6 Fabien
peut-être
qui semble être quand même plus plus
simple sans être forcément compliqué sur
H6 peut-être qu'il y aura G5 dans ces
cas-là peut-être un coup comme cavalier
G6 aussi tu peux aussi aller faire un
tour en G6
parce que les Noirs ne veulent pas
prendre mais le problème c'est que bon
c'est un peu relou quoi
costume NAS probablement cavalier H6 et
scorpion prend il y avait
la partie et là ça va être pour prendre
le 7 et dommage 5 pour essayer de s'en
sortir mais ma tante m'attendais ou même
que il prend ça
a l'air ouais ouais on est plus content
cavalier est trop fort ici Wesley qui
prend là encore son temps il veut pas
laisser la moindre chance à anial mais
tu reprends le 7 fous prends le 7 la
jauge annonce Mathen 6
dame prend pour essayer d'embrouiller
mais euh
ça s'appelle ça s'appelle un zéro ouais
Wesley impressionnant Royal serein
facile
bon
ouais c'est une variante un peu solide
des Noirs c'est symétrique souvent les
blancs prennent en C5 je crois que
peut-être le donner lui aussi
le D4 bon bah ce qu'il a fait
hyper connu
c'est un peu le même esprit que la
partie d'avant dans le sens où c'est un
peu chiant à jouer pour les Noirs mais
ça doit aller quoi
ouais c'est un peu relou quand même
tu préfères quand même avoir les blancs
pourquoi c'est chiant simplement on a
deux pions centraux contre un on a le
fougé deux qui tap on peut avoir des 4
fois F4 pour C1 en fait on a un peu de
vent je sais pas ça se voit c'est visuel
voilà la clé noir ils ont du mal à
sortir le fou c'est vite déjà
voilà bon après
oui ça dépend peut-être tu peux sécher
le truc t'activer bon bah déjà ce qui
est clair c'est que tu vas pas tout le
reste qui est à 500 quoi donc
tu vois leur vie c'est qui cette fois 4
comme ça tu vois ça j'en sais rien bah
voilà c'est du radire ça marche ou pas
mais il a joué des 7 mais peut-être
juste il connaît en fait bah du coup
faut prendre il y a B6
au cas où on nous demande si ça
mignalshine est top monde ou non bien
loin de là non pas du tout
peut-être qui végète un peu qui qui
arrive pas à progresser à passer un
palier là il bloque depuis deux ans
peut-être hein il bloque sur un palier
mais bonjour Après mais oui c'est pas
top top top c'est un excellent joueur
attention mais on parle pour top monde
pas vraiment
mais bon a priori donc
chez les jeunes ouais donc les Indiens
les deux meilleurs du moment c'est
Google c'est ungazing après on va voir
ce qu'ils vont donner mais c'est les
deux qui ont passé les 2007 ouais bon
bah oui les noirs sont mieux enfin je
veux dire bon on parle un peu d'autres
choses là mais en fait le problème dans
cette structure tiens juste pour en
revenir là c'est que certes les blancs
avantages au centre mais non bah c'est
éloigner à terme dans toutes les finales
c'est pas trop mal [ __ ] ils ont de la
colonne aussi
oui et donc tu peux pas faire tourner en
prise option à deux il y aura peut-être
des fois 4 qui ont été arrivé dessus dès
qu'il y a essayé de les machins donc en
fait c'était bien agencé les pièces ils
connaissait en fait je pense mais c'est
ça le problème en fait comme je te dis
ça c'est une position je sais pas c'est
vrai que visuellement ça a l'air cool
plutôt cool pour les blancs mais en fait
ça après noir ça va point final en fait
tu sacrifie B7 tu t'actives enfin déjà
de la même pas pris mais peut-être il
fallait prendre en fait quand même oui
c'est normal tu es pas moins bien que
les blancs au pire tu te fais sécher
c'est tout là tu peux être pire que ça
en fait tu peux être essoré
était déjà mené à zéro exactement donc
double essorage tu peux ne pas être bien
c'est vrai tu imagines Naka c'est pour
ça aussi qu'il était aussi dégoûté hier
on en parlait mais parce que tu sais que
si tu vas Wesley pour Naka je pense que
c'est vraiment freewin Sarine c'est
juste le style en plus qui lui
correspond c'est pour tu te nourris là
qui te tombent dessus tu les regardes
tomber quoi c'est l'hélicoptère monnaie
hein
t'as pas vraiment de belle casse tu
reviens tu vas te prendre X3 et si tu
fais F3 tu es dégoûté quoi enfin t'as
pas fait la Catalane pour être un pion
F3 mais bon si tu as pas le choix tu as
pas le choix
ah ça y est ça commence à pleurifier
côté Wesley mais bon la position est
tellement belle surtout pour le coup
j'ai quatre c'est un énorme classique
dans plein de trucs ghetto quoi tu es
content d'aller perdre ton temps pour
pour
tu bloques le pion tu replaces le fou
peut-être tu joues un petit tour vite
enfin ça va très bien mais je l'aimais
bien fou j'ai 4
ok bon 8 semble logique à triche
caractérisée quand même là Fabien
il a arrêté d'écouter de la musique donc
forcément
triche caractérisée c'est logique ou des
trois il a replacer le fou ici donc
ouais il s'est pas bloqué dans le pion
des seins qui se remet de l'autre côté
il colle le matin un peu pas de tour aux
deux pas de Tours c'est deux avec ce
fout des trois
fautes maintenant un petit peu à
contretemps mais c'était peut-être
toujours le bon coup quoi qu'il en soit
demande si ce serait une sorte de Neo
petroscien si on veut pourquoi pas ouais
il y a des similitudes mais il y a aussi
Sarine qui propose accepter
automatiquement par Wesley
bon un peu dommage peut-être s'il y a
une passe match
il est plutôt mieux mais bon rien n'est
fait en tout cas pour l'instant belle
gestion du match il a toujours pas été
mis en difficulté mais un an et demi à
0,5 et il aura les blancs la prochaine
et peut-être tu pourras mettre la
pression en tout cas Sarine
contrairement à ses matchs congrès n'est
pas arrivé à réagir dans la foulée de sa
défaite même il était Moder passer
proche de la correctionnelle donc début
de match maîtrisé pour ça en tout cas
faut prendre le match dans sa globalité
en fait c'est pas une partie prise comme
ça séparément c'est un match de 8
parties
et voilà alors c'est parti alors ça y
joue des modernes quoi donc il veut
essayer de compliquer un peu le jeu donc
avoir comment Wesley va traiter ça ce
qui fait C4 pour aller plus dans du D4
et ce qui fait que ici trois normal et
ce qui fait des ventes solides à base de
keyev 3 C3 et compagnie voilà les trois
choix on va dire
en tout cas
dans ta position ce qu'il a fait et là à
voir dans ce cas donc faut 3 à 6 et H4
c'est bien
bon tu as d'autres couples sont bien
mais
H4 en général c'est c'est recommandé tu
pousses un point tout simplement
un coup H3 conservateur c'est un coup
Dame des deux directions
est-ce que c'est un coup malheureusement
la case est trop bien défendue
mais ça pourrait le devenir un jour mais
c'est un peu l'idée de maintenir ce qui
est danger de l'entendre donc H4 H6 pas
mal il veut pas faire H5 avec les noirs
pour ne pas donner la caisse là tu peux
faire H5 et de gagner la H5 G5 F4 là le
truc
tu peux aussi
avoir faire grand rock et retarder pour
après mais H5 G5 F4
et au pire il perd et il lui arrive rien
de grave quoi
c'est vrai que tu as une tranquillité
quand tu prends le lead comme ça très
tôt
tranquille et d'esprit il joue avec F3
donc il joue encore un système différent
mais il a l'Espace il a tout pour lui à
Wesley
ouais bon après il veut peut-être jouer
pour jouer 4 G5 et 5 à ce moment-là et
avoir F4 F5 et partir comme ça quoi et
ça enfermé ici un cheval et qui avait H3
aussi c'est sûrement un coup pour les
blancs
on va voir quelle mise en place il
décide en tout cas il prend son temps ça
arrive lui qui clique peut-être un peu
trop vite d'ailleurs
attention de pas à se mettre trop en
danger
bon écoute tu fais des coups normaux
après c'est vrai que sont possibles mais
il a censé top il y a des élections H4
et j'aurais acheté c'est pas H5 donc là
pour faire
et connaissez
jamais facile à jouer pour pour les
noirs et pour les blancs il y a pas de
contact
avec les Blancs tu as une décision
est-ce que je prends ces cinq ou pas si
tu prends pas il va continuer de
t'avancer dessus si tu prends en général
il prend du cavalier et dans une
structure sicilienne un dragon en fait
donc là ce que je conseille pas c'est
des 5
parce que tout le fou G7 ça te fera rien
bon tu fermes le [ __ ] c'est pas lui le
danger
donc soit tu prends soit attendre te
faire prendre mais bon souvent tu prends
parce que les normes vont peut-être pas
prendre et donc voilà comme je te dis ta
structure du dragon
et c'est une gueule de sicilienne tout
d'un coup oui sur internet mais tu as le
cavalier 8 enfin qu'il y a pas de mal à
sortir mais une fois que tu as fait
cavalier F6 tu as pas petit rock non et
puis KFC c'est peut-être 5 qui est
désagréablement là ici oui
pour faire cavalier F6 slash sur derager
vers C15 donc deux idées qui est des 5
donc il inter enfin il interdit pas
complètement mais sur cavalier 5 il veut
peut-être se diriger vers B6 bon ça
sachant que les Noirs ils peuvent aussi
faire H5 ils ont fait H6 au début et
puis ils disent oui bon j'ai envie de
faire H5 comme ça je peux OK
c'est pas c'est pas interdit quoi voilà
ouais c'est je t’annonce cavalier prend
et fous des cartes c'est annoncé là tu
peux pas faire plus pleutre et là du
coup cavalier C3 du cavalier c'est
qu'elle est C3 et ca validé 7 fous des
quatre à ce moment-là mais c'est
peut-être pas mal pour les blancs
commence par H5 mais ça c'est pas
l'autre ça
anecdotique mais je veux dire par là
c'est sa garde tous les mêmes plans dans
la position mais sur qui est proche 5 il
veut quoi il veut g46 pour bien échanger
tout ok
c'est 3 MC5 ou C3
[Musique]
sacrifie la canne et il vient faire
cavalier 3 oui bon là il va falloir
quand même se calmer Wesley c'est trop
c'est beaucoup trop ce qu'il fait parce
que là en fait on rentre dans le
territoire du calcul en fait ça devient
une position irrationnelle là il y a
plus rien à dire stratégiquement en fait
c'est qualité de plus mais tout est
bizarre parce que
tu as des trucs qui avance ok mais il
part sur le Tour G8 fois je suis
pourquoi il a fait ça ouais c'est
bizarre quand même alors qu'il pouvait
faire un tranquille qui a essayé trois
se faire sa petite nulle bah c'est
bizarre ça colle pas la stratégie de
match parce qu'en fait la partie d'avant
bah il est vraiment mieux on pressant
tranquille sans risque là c'est à risque
enfin je te dis pas que c'est mal joué
en fait concrètement c'est pas forcément
c'est peut-être bien c'est peut-être
mauvais on n'en sais rien mais oui mais
il peut perdre
ça colle pas avec avec la stratégie de
match ouais mais bon après si c'était
des machines au cœur froid ça se
truc c'est que ça joue beaucoup plus
facilement avec les Blancs c'est vrai
que je cherche aussi une tarif pas à
taper en fait peut-être pour début de
dessin
autre plan c'est fou ces 6 tours B8 dame
B7 B4 enfin faut se déplacer pour aller
faire une perception en tout cas parce
que la tour G8 bon bah elle est là mais
spéciale il faudrait pouvoir transférer
ce tour sinon via je sais pas où il y a
G5 la G6 est tourné mais bon
je vais remettre en place tu vois là la
jauge s'excite un petit peu à cause de
D5
ou tu as envie de faire enfin préparer
alors lui il le fait direct le champion
il va tourner 8 et c'est pas invisible
je veux dire ouais après des cinq pions
prend tour des 8 j'ai peut-être fou F4
quand même
d'un coup tu tapes F3 tu te remets vers
le centre tu regardes vers le roi c'est
logique en fait et de deux qualités de
plus donc tout décolonne une fois que le
pion en dé est passé pour je sais pas où
D6 par là-bas quoi quelque part donc
c'est un coup c'est noir qui leur
améliore leur position en tout cas on va
voir si il y arrive complexe en position
est-ce que les blancs peuvent réussir à
faire jouer ce fou je pense qu'il a
c'est trop long parce que si tu réussis
à le téléporter en a deux tu serais beau
tu serais magnifique c'est très bizarre
ce qu'a fait Wesley 4
et des 5
[Musique]
voilà il se fait jugé
dans la tronche quoi alors après
peut-être qu'il veut 5 fou F2 D5 il y a
peut-être une dame qui arrivent
non mais faut regarder
je peux comprendre la E5 fois F2 D5
damage 6 puis on prend le 4 tour 1
si on prend F3 d'un H7 je sais pas enfin
c'est ou cavalier FC chèque vous prend
d'âme prank à ça en l'air mais tu auras
sûrement E4
quand même après
mais ça doit pas aller pour pour les
blancs il y a trop de pions il y a aussi
E5 fois F2 D5 fois H4 intermédiaire mais
là dessus il y a peut-être tourner 6
et cavaliers G3 pour essayer de profiter
du clouage pour faire kf5 en vrai son
jauge c'est hyper compliqué tu voulais
faire quoi roi des 7 je ne viens pas
après tu vas perdre rachis c'est quand
la dame vient t'as encore F7 sous
pression il a fait 5
je pense que Sarine va la gagner celle
là voilà là en fait tu fais un truc
super pas clair et je sais pas
le truc logique bah après on va voir si
Wesley avait une idée cette fois H4
c'est dommage 7 ou quoi
[Musique]
tu peux te faire avoir par Sarine alors
tu dominait tranquillement en position
calme la partie 1 et 2 donc continue
enfin tu as trouvé un débat ou tu
domines donc continue le débat surtout
quand tu t'appelles ça
si tu es en domination tu es quand même
très bien quoi
tu sors de ton pain quotidien quoi tu
t'appelles soit tu domines tu es le roi
du monde
en plus quand tu prends le 4 même si tu
te fais reprendre un jour il y aura G4
en l'air non mais c'est terrible
c'est une non partie quelque part il est
né au score il te fait une moderne
exprès pour que tu t'énerves et que et
voilà pas assez typiquement le truc
quand je disais l'autre jour c'est une
version pour jouer pour le bien avec les
mains c'est que tu peux te [ __ ] dans
la merde mais tu peux faire tilter
l'adversaire ouais ça énerve
tu t'as juste le drapeau rouge devant le
taureau quoi mais normalement en fait ça
devait pas être un taureau
[Musique]
un match qui a du mal à s'envoler pour
le moment partie un peu raté à la
première de Sarine nul rapide à la
deuxième
là c'est une partie maintenant vraiment
ratée saut pour le moment c'est
EF c'est logique alors dame D1 ça donne
envie de foudre malheureusement il y a
C4
et
c'est 4 ça nasdam d8m
par contre c'est une menace latente dans
la position mais faut d'abord s'occuper
du roi
s'occuper du roi on prend un F3 pourquoi
pas parce que c'est encore un pion ça
fait des puntos centraux ça fait que G4
va être attaqué ça fait que 4 peut
arriver ça fait pas mal de choses
ça se prend vraiment pas faire ce serait
à 5 aussi
tu vas jamais le faire mais il faut pas
faire quoi attention elle a fait puis on
prend F3 plutôt logique
facile
les coups facile
[Musique]
et sur B4 il veut peut-être aller
bouffer carrément à 6 après donc c'est
ça c'est un autre truc bien c'est quand
tu feras genre des coups de Tours ou
quoi il y a plus maintenant
un jour peut-être en tout cas le A4 il
est parti tempo
bah c'est bien ça va
de faire un son
prend à 4 ou C4 il menacera
mais donc du coup
si j'ai envie de te dire en voulant
éviter toutes les merdes et là on voit
la jauge qui remonte
qui redescend à 140 mais
ouais mais bon tu sens que contre un
ordi il aurait pas fini il serait déjà
fait égaliser en fait instantanément non
mais en fait toujours toujours avoir non
mais là va être bizarre oui parce que
c'est des trucs qui se met à réfléchir
en fait trop
Assimil pour finir c'est normal de faire
gaffe mais pas de prendre cinq minutes
pour faire de la merde enfin
non mais c'est vrai bah c'est toujours
pareil ouais c'est prendre du temps pour
faire de la merde si j'avais une bonne
idée de façon et là
tu arrives à une vingt chacun la jauge
est heureuse
mais on voit que c'est pas si simple
tout d'un coup ce qui se passe bah ouais
puis surtout qu'il y a égalité autant et
puis c'est la dynamique d'une partie
aussi
c'est qu'en fait tu contrôle plus rien
Wesley il était à deux doigts
d'abandonner enfin je suis sûr qu'il l'a
vu 4 3 c'est sûr qu'il a conquis que
c'était gagnant là tout d'un coup ça
devient chaud mais le 7 tu te rends fou
des trois tempo et tout d'un coup et tu
te fais enchaîner les coups la position
elle devient chaude et Menin zéro tu as
le chat en face de toi qui met des coups
de griffes de partout enfin tu es dans
la merde en fait tu es vraiment dans la
merde on va crier au génie finalement
bah non mais c'est enfin c'est terrible
quoi et il te reste 20 secondes c'est
dans la merde tu sais plus quoi jouer tu
sues
ah surtout prends il veut
ça c'est le genre de coup qu'est ce que
ça m'énerve quand j'ai peu de temps
parce que tu sais pas ce qu'il faut que
tu fasses
pourquoi pas et là il va faire [ __ ] en
F2 et 4
tout le temps énervé quand on joue en
fait
là tu sais que tu as été con en fait
moi aussi c'est de la merde c'est
l'histoire de ma vie en fait mais là tu
sens le Beko
heureusement tu dois avoir un coup de
un coup de fou B7 et sur pousser 5 tu
peux ah mais attention il faut
écarts pour l'instant c'est peut-être
pas si grave ouais mais peut-être tu
fais
[Musique]
bah sinon je passe par A8
tu as compris le piège bah faut jouer et
ça va répéter ah c'est beau si ça fait
nul mais tu peux pas mais c'est pas
possible non c'est l'autre qui joue pour
le gars mais maintenant B4 gagne
regardez la jauge qui s'envole en plus
B4 c'est le coup facile
dans la merde partout même sur un coup
débile comme quoi c'est hyper facile
raté après facile si tu peux tromper
mais c'est pas un coup dur
quand même
on crie au génie
la différence de niveau est trop grande
en fait
Bahia
c'est un tellement de
lucidité
tant pis
dans le match là en fait le match est
fini et on montre ce qu'il a raté bah a
priori c'est le dame C7 qui est le fout
un peu dans la sauce il pouvait pousser
les puntos au centre c'était simple
4 4 il semble que l'idée c'était
vraiment à 4 je pense
[Musique]
de boire pour déstresser lors de finale
à en jeu alors pas vraiment mais il y a
un truc que tu peux faire qui est connu
c'est de mettre un petit peu d'eau dans
ta bouche mais pas de la boire en fait
de la garder
et c'est censé te calmer un petit peu
mais
après bon
j'en sais rien à quel point ça marche ou
pas
je vois pas les joueurs de haut niveau
le faire
stratégie chacun fait un peu personne
bon du coup ouais
on peut voir le plan de vlades de faire
fout B6 faut prendre cheval
[Musique]
on avait fait une vidéo c'était qui
c'était fearuja qui avait fait ça contre
eux contre Carlson d'ailleurs rappelle
cette cette fin de magnifique partie non
mais ça me dit quelque chose que fero
jazz
c'était aux grandes chaises
là il a quasiment une enfin pas une
balle de match encore mais presque ouais
il a vu le DVD non mais franchement
c'est dur de savoir enfin je veux dire
c'est ta ville DVD tu sais mais sinon tu
sais pas c'est intéressant
il prend
un truc tactique
incroyable non juste échange et tu as
plus de pions tu as plus de pions isolé
tu as la paire de fou mais même juste un
fou à 6
pour combien de temps
ça fait un peu penser
finalement aux Écossais ce qu'il y a des
deux
absolument rien obtenu dans l'ouverture
les trois meilleurs de la compétition je
pense c'était vraiment d'un camura duda
et so
qui était vraiment dans le dans la même
partie de tableau tous les trois et qui
je pense aurait pu dominer les cinq
autres sans sans grand problème
ça c'est vraiment hyper égal non
oui
à 5 encore non bon sinon en fait on joue
pour ces 5 dégâts enfin puis on passait
central on le pousse à fond il va nous
bloquer et on reste tout liquide si on
veut faire comme ça c'est ce qui veut
faire en fait
il se casse
probablement pour pouvoir doubler et
puis c'est 5 et puis des quatre
après tu peux reprendre du pion ou des
tours et des pièces lourdes pour tout
liquider sur la colonne des aussi
pour f4,5 mais c'est le truc risqué mais
qui va se prendre mais bon
on va pas perdre et se faire de mater
enfin il y a plus un matériel de ouf et
le pion dépassé va trop être chiant
c'est-à-dire que la dame des trois
pourra pas quitter sinon et ça devrait
partir pour ça en tout cas
ok après tu auras 8 c'est aussi ça va
bien sûr tu défends tout évite les
cloches tout va je me suis refait les
parties
de l'année dernière c'était autre chose
ah c'était un beau match ça mais c'est
il y a deux ans par contre ouais l'année
dernière Maxime c'était incliné au
premier tour contre Fabiano carwana qui
avait sorti son plus beau match de blitz
de savent carrière en fait
qui après a montré des progrès qu'il
avait fait en blitz mais c'est la
première fois qu'on le voyait un niveau
un peu supérieur à d'habitude et nous
allons
pas trop pas réputé pour être un grand
little piano c'était une de ses
faiblesses alors c'était pas un mauvais
joueur évidemment tout est relatif mais
par rapport au niveau qu'il est en lente
il y avait une énorme différence
et petit à petit un peu combler le gap
il a ouais c'est pas mal c'est ça
logique
et là bon courage à NiAl pour progresser
dans cette position parce que là
peut-être qu'en fait je me disais tu
peux ne pas faire des quatre et juste
encore mieux petite nul rapide Fabien
pour clôturer la journée en 12 minutes
de jeu logique
du coup on aura une belle pause de 21h
jusqu'à la prochaine partie c'est ça et
j'ai envie de dire NiAl qui a peut-être
même dans la tête abandonnée toute
chance de battre de battre Wesley ici
gagner deux ne pas perdre pour aller
chercher un Armageddon éventuellement
on verra demain comment ça se passe mais
oui très peu de chances pour lui en
revenir ouais match match insipide
malheureusement l'écart de niveau entre
les deux hommes et bien trop important
écoutez les amis on se retrouvera demain
pour la suite de ce match ce serait très
étonné qu'il échappe que ce global chat
Championship 2022 échappe à West les
sauts mais on n'est jamais à l'abri
d'une d'une surprise dans le sport donc
on se retrouvera demain sur les coups de
18h pour la suite et fin de ce tournoi
merci de d'avoir suivi cette première
journée de de finale avec nous et on
vous retrouve demain ciao ciao ciao le
Fab